are you pulling out all the stops to
convince Otani to stay during free
agency 100 who wouldn't want that guy on
the team how much do you think he'll get
in free agency I think he's anywhere
between five and six do you know how
many M's that is that's a lot of M I
mean I asked a lot of people this how
many years do you think he has of doing
both I would say of doing both five or
six yeah that's tough I mean you know we
play every day like we know how to grind
it especially it's his level he's not
just out there just getting some hits
and clogging up baseball he's getting
off the mound starting and then he's
leading off the inning I gotta give it
to him bro he works man but I think any
between five and six that's so much
money